capital de burkina faso la embajada
francesa fue atacada por manifestantes
no queremos no queremos más a Francia ya
no queremos a Francia en África ya no la
queremos abajo Francia llamamos a Rusia
a partir de ahora ya no queremos a
Francia abajo a Francia estas tensiones
se producen tras el anuncio de la
destitución por parte del ejército de
Polaris damiba este también había
llegado al poder en un golpe de estado
el pasado mes de enero después de
derrocar al presidente
desacreditado por el aumento de la
violencia yihadista los manifestantes
apoyan ahora al autoproclamado líder
golpista y brahim traoré
damiba ha fracasado y la gente no está
contenta y de hecho salimos hoy para
mostrar al mundo que no queremos a este
hombre nunca más
Francia condenó la violencia contra su
embajada según París los atentados
Fueron perpetrados por manifestantes
manipulados por una campaña de
desinformación la nueva junta en el
poder llamó a la calma David
les invitamos a ocuparse libremente de
sus asuntos y a desistir de cualquier
acto de violencia y vandalismo que pueda
empañar los esfuerzos realizados desde
la noche del 30 de septiembre de 2022
Especialmente los que puedan perpetrarse
contra la embajada francesa o la base
militar francesa
El capitán traoré era hasta ahora el
comandante del regimiento de artillería
de la ciudad Norteña de kaya
especialmente afectada por los atentados
y aristas según varias fuentes de
seguridad su golpe revela profundas
diferencias en el seno del ejército con
los dos levantamientos militares en Mali
en agosto de 2020 y mayo de 2021 y el de
Guinea en septiembre de 2021 Este es el
quinto golpe de estado en África
occidental desde 2020